do you feel Unstoppable like they're
gonna throw it to you and nobody's going
to be able to cover you because you have
so many big plays today I mean I I
always feel like that I always feel like
you know nobody can you know guard me
you know as as a competitor I mean I
feel like if you ask anybody in our room
you know they'll say the same thing
can't nobody guard me or them or just
I just feel like that's just a
competitive mindset you know I want the
ball well that sounds kind of like
you know crazy but um
yeah like I just feel like can't nobody
guard me
right
first time now that you get to apply
what you've learned in the off season
right a few more seconds
oh man like everything was more fluid
this year because last year man I was
just banking on my speed and just
banking on me just out running guys but
this year you know I was I was in my bag
a little bit more on release moves and
just you know routes at the top and
stuff like that that's how that's how I
was able to get my first catch you know
I had a dagger
um last year we ran the same exact route
and I wasn't open but this year it's
like a whole lot different like um
because I know how to run it and I know
exactly how many steps I need to be at
and stuff like that so
um yeah everything was different man I'm
not just counting on my on my speed
obviously after the catch I am but